hey what's going on is bill birnes time
for the Thursday afternoon just before
Friday Monday morning podcast and I just
check it in on you seeing how your weeks
going as you're slogging your way
through your cubicle life something you
never wanted you know but who you gonna
blame laughter you gonna blame society
like all of these people on social
networks is it ever their fault anyways
I have a special guest as promised on
the Monday morning podcast I said
goddamn it and I delivered we have the
amazing the unbelievably talented and
hilarious
Bill Hader star of the new incredible
show on HBO berry starring Henry Winkler
Stephen root I was my cheat sheet was
who's the woman plays your girlfriend
she crushes it
Sarah gold oh my god she's amazing yeah
she's amazing she's amazing and it's
eight incredible episodes thank you I
saw the first two and then my link
expired and then I couldn't get it to
play I got a new link and then I melted
down and my wife said you're bringing
tension into the house so that was
that's been my experience so far but
having said that I absolutely loved
loved the first two that I saw and
there's another add the other actor day
with the alopecia there it oh yeah
Anthony Kerrigan oh my god no ho Hank
great name incredible actor so I was
actually just to give people a
background I was gonna interview all of
you guys at the now-defunct nerdmelt
yeah that's gone because of that
incident I believe yeah that guess what
happened to me yeah so you you was
supposed to come down there with Henry
Stephen and the other guys and you have
a peanut allergy I'm not allergy and
they gave they gave me well here's the
thing it's my own I blame myself
so I can have almonds I'm okay with
almonds but all the nuts I'm bad with so
I go I'll coffee and you all can I have
almond milk in it like a racist it's
just like nuts right just nuts you stay
with your own you stay with the almonds
all these other ones get him out of my
house all right you're a painted
supremacy I've never heard of that I
thought if you had like a peanut allergy
oh I I found that out on a movie I had
something oh wow that has almonds in it
and I had it and I go I'm fine and then
I went home and I had an EpiPen and sat
there with almonds and ate it and what
is an EpiPen that's what you take in
case you having motion you do a stabbing
motion and you're like yeah I stat you
stab yourself with the EpiPen so takes
what like your blood pressure right now
it just shoots you full of adrenaline
basically and then you just you're able
to breathe it gets a big shot of this so
so when you drank this so you were
supposed to come in and all of a sudden
somebody basically gave the equivalent
to you of a couple poison they gave me
well almond milk but it was this fancy
coffee place and they were like well we
have an almond the cashew blend that
comes and I can't have cashews so I had
that and I took a drink of it backstage
excited about to go on and I went I
gotta go a couple when you drink that
how quick do you know this is like it
yeah yeah you don't get you don't get
bit by Cobra I go I'm gonna wait what
can do this onee minutes I could do the
podcast I'm fine my legs all black and
blue and I can't really feel my feet
anymore and yeah you bet I'm fine it was
just one Fang yeah I'm fine and my dad
with the book the biggest bomb it was my
dad's a giant fan here so my dad was
really excited too and he flew in
because we had the premiere and so he
wanted to see it and I go I gotta go and
he was like what fine because you're
fine you're fine you're fine I go oh I
gotta go I gotta go
you can stay here go and he's like I'll
go you know let's get you some benadryl
and all that stuff okay so so what
happens is your throat closes oh yeah
and so guy someone ran out and got me
benadryl and that that was fine and then
I got home how bad is like how much are
you laboring breathing I'm breathing
fine it's just I said I I it was in my
mouth for only a couple of seconds and
then I spit it out but it was enough to
make everything start to kind of it was
like hives inside your mouth and you
throw my go yes it was awful so then
when you take the benadryl how long does
he chose that out and then you get
groggy
and then I did the EpiPen which then
makes you all jacked up and then I went
into the premiere and yeah sucks also
you able to work then that night yeah I
had to yeah it was like HBO's like we
need you yeah
so do you trap when you travel do you
have those things with you mm-hmm
I have my backpack out right there in
that's the whole reason could I buy one
of those yeah you can go prescription
for it yeah like the writers Roman F is
a family you know when you just get like
burned out like I can't think of any
more funny sure an EpiPen just stab
yourself yeah let's just do epi pins
yeah well no it's like this dumb thing
that when you do it everyone thinks it's
but it's it's it's just more the motion
of it looks more severe than it actually
is it's just like a little pinprick but
it's like buried into this you go
through your pants no you can't pull
your pants down and go right on your leg
and then but uh so you stab it and then
you push to push the thing down at the
same time yeah you can't tell me you
don't feel a little bit like John Rambo
yeah no you totally do yeah but I'm such
a wimp that I'm you know well I want you
to know you not being there really threw
me off my game because I've never hosted
one of those before so it's an honor
that I got to do it and one of my goals
was I I was just like I am NOT asking
Henry Winkler about playing Arthur
Fonzarelli I am that was my am gonna I'm
gonna do anything I'm gonna talk about
night shift I left you with nothing
which yeah and then by the end I was
just like they were helping me through
the interview and then somehow I just
said I go you know I'm running out of
stuff but my goal is is I'm not bringing
up you-know-who and then he just broke
into the character just saying like you
know that character maybe a lot of money
and put my kids through college I can't
do the font then I was all excited like
oh my god he did the fog oh and he does
it you it's like it's like you know
Mickey Mouse showing I'm John Mulaney
said it's like Mickey Mouse showing up
person it's like a thing I grew up my oh
that's television that's terrible and
he'll he said it to Alec Berg and I once
and Alec co-created Barry he's not a
the very effusive guy he was standing
behind me and Henry told this story
we're not emotional yes you know huh
don't stand up I've done stand-up
through the whole that whole region up
there Finland was the funniest one they
were just sitting there they were trying
to solve the problem of the job like I
would sit there and I'm doing the joke
and it was just quiet quiet quiet and
then if somebody's just fine goes why
didn't you just blah blah just like is
that what you [ __ ] guys are doing I
go you don't need to solve these this
isn't like a self-help thing that's just
I don't you just kick your wife out of
the house yes bury her in the backyard
and say she went to a mother's to do
that yes so if that was Finland dope I
definitely noticed there was a huge
difference was at the Baltic Sea I don't
know like Norway and Sweden as a certain
level of emotionally disconnected and
then when you go to the over there with
this spoon and with Russia and they
actually defeated Russia and had to give
up part of their land because they
paired up with Hitler you know they went
between the two craziest people in the
last century it's like who went to the
crazier one which and who lost yeah I
don't know if you they went to the crazy
one they were they were equals they were
like if there was a way that they both
could have won the war and lived yeah I
guess the other guy lived right style
live I don't know [ __ ] about history
like they could sit back like you know
old NBA players yeah like when wilt and
Bill Russell get together they could be
talking about murdering people and their
knees are bad they can't really walk
around much but though they yeah it was
this ya know Alec is a he's hilarious I
mean he wrote on Seinfeld and Curb Your
Enthusiasm he's a very funny guy but
he's not he's very kind of quiet and and
Henry did the Fonz he just told a story
and I said I to tell all these people
you know because Henry him life is very
kind of hello how are you oh that's when
you mean or you see him just talking
that's what makes it even more
that guy came out of this guy yeah he's
like I was on the phone in my car
hands-free okay being safe being safe
and then you know then it'll be like oh
you know the Fonz would say eh but like
the Red Sea you know he would do
something and Halleck was behind me and
he went oh my god yeah he it was the
most efficient Alec he just went oh I
can't believe that it gave us chills
yeah well because it like like you said
when you talk to the guy it's nowhere
it's like Mel Blanc when Mel Blanc with
ya voices like you'd be like this
there's no way this guy does Bugs Bunny
or he does you send me Sam again I
didn't hear him in any event I feel like
with him when he's just talking you just
like this can't be the guy that played
that guy and all of a sudden he does the
voice this is hilarious
now I'm gonna sit here talking about it
being the Fonz for this whole because I
laughed and then you were stuck it
sounds to me like you blew off the
interview and I'm not buying this whole
[ __ ] stabbing yourself then somehow
you write the fire it was a premiere
that was super nerdmelt to talk of some
jackasses podcast I get it those super
bottles that an HBO premiere for Barry
no is all a casting about some Hooters
chicks they were working there no no but
I they they had me know it was a thing
where it was one of those things you
leave and then HBO is going oh my god oh
my god you know the thing is it's his
show you got a you know gotta be well
what do we got a can we send a doctor
over there can we do anything what can
we do and they're going old school
centered hookers and they go yeah yeah
yeah like this is dr. feelgood and you
know yeah he's my magic briefcase all
right you're gonna be up in no time
buddy well everybody I know that has
been watching it it's just been like you
know what I love about it and what I
wanted to talk to you about is I love
when somebody that's known for doing
comedy gets to do some drama stuff
because for some reason they think that
I don't know who the comedian was that
screwed it up for the rest of us I want
to know who that person was and also who
the person was that [ __ ] up so bad
that we all actors
I have to get there like nine hours
before you're gonna get called just sit
there with the fake mustache glued on
your face it's just like who [ __ ] up
who [ __ ] up Fatty Arbuckle who wasn't
fired Fatty Arbuckle just was always
twenty minutes thirty hours late thirty
hours late so now that I bring you when
you gotta get the Arbuckle rule I want
all these [ __ ] here now my word am
my worst whenever I got called I was
went to a set at four o'clock in the
afternoon and I didn't work didn't utter
a word until 1:00 in the morning oh I've
done that where I get called on a I
remember Tropic Thunder there was this
huge party scene and it was just one of
those things where I just learned that
it's all communication where Ben
Stiller's directing a Ben and Ben I
think he kept saying Rob my character's
name is Rob but there's also an actor
named Rob and he was like Rob should be
in there right you know and the first ad
went Oh bills not bills not working
today so they would wake me up call me
fly the Colombian I hope going at 2:00
in the morning this out and wherever
we're shooting like Hawaii or something
I go in put me a make up and I would
just sit in my trailer and then fine I
get tired you know kind of late what am
i doing you know yeah I'm not in the
scene right so I go to set and Ben would
go well [ __ ] are you doing here then two
days later hey we need you to come in
what's going on what are you doing here
and he goes no Rob Rob the actor Rob not
the [ __ ] showed up twice you know
it's funny waiting in those trailers I
actually understood my dog more yeah I
was just thinking why does this thing
[ __ ] sleep all the time and it's
basically if you have nothing to do it
goes back to survival where it's like
we're gonna shut down your body and just
store this energy so like the level of
tired you get but Hannah my dog know
every episode of the Tyra Banks Show
because that seems to be the only thing
on television I've never had the TV work
never works it's just something like
whatever signal you just hear the other
actor next to you clearing their throat
every couple of hours
and then from with their agent I I'm not
gonna do that they want me to do this
I'm not gonna do it well let's let's
promote it a little bit here because as
far as like it's on HBO ok the final
episode is this Sunday yeah there's
eight of them and if people want to go
back and watch all them I imagine in
2018 HBO has a way to yeah it was really
yeah HBO go you if you have that you can
go check it out and I think Amazon Hulu
those places
well I'm old-school in that I like to
watch an episode I like the old way well
you watched it and then you had a wait a
week for it to come out and then and
then another one went and and like like
I don't know all the shows that I
watched you try to guess what was gonna
happen and now like there's all these
great shows they're just dumb and people
just sit down it's like it's like the
greatest bottle of wine ever and you
like shotgunning it was amazing and then
like what else can I have now and it's
just and I also have a I feel for like
the amount of work that was put into
this cuz that's what happens with the
[ __ ] cartoon I'm doing which just
this I actually did a cartoon after
because of those getting called at 4:00
in the afternoon not working til when
I'm like dude [ __ ] this live-action [ __ ]
I'm gonna do a cartoon where I just show
up when a baseball hat in sweat pants
and I didn't realize that it was like 90
times slower and then the thing comes
out and people will watch it all in one
night that's great when's the next
season coming out it's just like I can't
well might as well just be a movie you
know what I mean it's like I don't know
but I like it that you do this and then
for eight weeks people are talking about
there's like a level the high intensity
level that's it's fun having people come
up to me you know my kids school or
whatever going hey this is what's gonna
happen
he's like Steven root he's a figment of
his imagination right it's not real oh
yeah you might be right I got you
figured out [ __ ] alright I used to
watch lost I know where you're going
with this yeah it's all figments of some
Mouse's imagination right yeah
but anyway you know something I actually
something I want to bring up before I
forget is that you know that you're from
Tulsa Oklahoma and I was telling you
earlier that that is one of my favorite
cities to perform stand-up and they got
the brady theater there which evidently
some ridiculous race riot happened
really I guess so I mean I walk in there
as a white guy I'm like this has a nice
body this feels like really great why is
it so comfortable
yeah and it's it's then they got all
this grateful because all these all
these people who'd never been there when
I told him I'm in Tulsa Oklahoma
everyone's like oh Jesus Christ you know
what are you gonna [ __ ] go ride a
bull out there like go cow-tipping yeah
and I didn't understand like how like
the the food there is incredible yeah
massive amounts of hipsters it's the
exact opposite thing that you would
picture but that old theater there yeah
is that George Carlin there once I
remember there's a first comedy show I
ever saw what yeah what year did you see
him I was young my dad it was a thing
where I got to get snuck into the thing
but my dad I saw many - yeah and I've
seen him and just my face hurting from
laughing and just it and not knowing
that he did like two hours I don't know
what it was it was super long but to me
I was I'll keep going keep going you
know and and just leaving on this high
and just going wow that was did that
have an effect that you you like at that
point did you already know you wanted to
get into comedy or no I mean I to me
that just seemed like I mean I I was
someone I did I and I still have a very
anxious having to get up in front of
people and so I the idea of going up
there alone and telling jokes and how
quick II was but I loved watching
stand-up my dad's giant fan of San to
stand up and so and in the 80s and that
you know every TV you know yeah the A&E
the even at The Improv the mtv half-hour
kind of watch all of those watches I've
saw those I mean I would run into like
Jeff Garlin and be like do you see
everything Adam West Adam West is gonna
be what bagel and he gets hit whether
you you you
our comedy hours yeah maybe yeah and you
went wide how did you know and then when
I met Judd Apatow for the first time I
go you used to do a bit about a you know
your nose you know being stuffed up and
how it switches you know you know you
get congested and one nostril goes in a
nostril and yeah I remember that but
that can freak people out I remember I
forget the name of the comedian but he
had this great bit he was talking about
I ran into the guy I don't even member
his name but I was one of my favorite
bits that I saw from one of those
evening at The Improv and he was talking
about how he was the youngest kid in
this big family and how strict the
parents were with the older kids and by
the time it got down to him it was you
know it was basically the only rule was
no heroin in the living room and then
one of my favorite tags of all time it
was just like Brian you're not using one
of the good spoons and I was just like
you know for a clean joke and all I
really loved I got to actually run into
him and tell him and I remember just
talking to that guy and I'm just looking
at me like how the [ __ ] does this kid oh
my god I remember Bob Nelson that guy
there was a guy Bob Nelson we do and
then the I saw him open for Rodney
Dangerfield Italy right after back this
back to school came out dude that summer
at great woods yeah in Mansfield
Massachusetts I saw Rodney Dangerfield
and then a few weeks later I saw Eddie
Murphy on the Rautureau and the weather
girl has open weather and girls opened
up they sing it's rainin men yeah and
they were big girls and I remember he
came out was doing all these jokes about
I gotta check out the stage because the
weather back when you could fat-shamed
people and he had like the purple suit
on and all of that says he did he always
close with his dad eating tinker toys
and the the food the the toy thing
remember that I don't remember what he
closed I mean Eddie Eddie we would eat
that whole thing that he would do is do
cuz and that was a thing seen raw which
now you watch Ron you're like geez or
some stuff you can't but that doesn't I
know I know but it's just thirty years
ago but you go like yeah SNL you would
watch sometime you guys got to watch
wrong and
would come back and go why did you find
that funny it was so offensive and
everything I got while I'd you know what
about the thing at the end you know I
would just try to concentrate on the
thing I found oh no and I watched that
thing it makes me sad that he stopped
yeah he was 25 years old and when he was
talking about you know the level success
he got to and thinking about getting
married and see Johnny Carson getting
divorced and all of that stuff and
saying you know women get half that's
[ __ ]
know something let me get half and that
woman goes that's right he goes nah
that's [ __ ] it was like he was going
to that next level where it's like oh
now this guy is gonna you know start
saying what he thinks about all this
stuff because you know that delirious
was amazing yeah but it was you know
Ralph Kramden having sexual you know
yeah yeah he was like you've seen this
guy finding his voice and and then I
mean who knew that I would go see him
and then that was actually like the
ferry yeah well I think when he did that
the thing at the end of raw was the
thing I saw you know is he when I was
young and it went wow he's just by
himself you might as well be by himself
in his room you know what I mean it was
like he went into this other place you
know it wasn't like jokes you know what
I mean it was like he's just talking and
he just went to this place and in it's
the thing I'm never as funny I the
funniest I'll ever be is in the
lunchroom with my friends and they were
all funnier than me
high school was funny I was way funnier
than me and I still see those guys and
they'll just like they'll send me a text
about one of my friends hated three
billboards that movie and his text made
me laugh harder than anything that I've
read any comedian I know all I do is
hang around with comedy people and I'll
and I'm like what you know he works at a
window store and Oklahoma someplace so
funny well just how they lived their
life I got a buddy of mine Joe DeRosa
was open and for me
and you know it was after show we did in
Boston I got all my Boston fights you
know hanging out
and one of my buddies offered to buy a
round of drinks are all order and drinks
and my buddy Joe ordered a White Russian
and my friend was just done with him and
he came up he goes dude what's up with
you boy
I go what's the matter he goes he just
sorted a White Russian and I didn't
really think about us I got Russians he
likes you know whatever that movie what
to do and then the end of the night I'm
walking back with Joe is your psyche
okay you know like hang on what are you
friends was he was like really friendly
and he was like talking to me that all
of a sudden out of nowhere he just
stopped talking it's just like it was I
was all based on the fact that he
ordered a White Russian and we were well
into our 30s like late 30s and this guy
still to this day I remember long don't
trust that guy I don't know anybody like
that I remember a long time ago he for
some reason was giving the
responsibility to watch the house of
this married couple and of course so he
immediately has this all over there and
we're getting hammered and and he's
taking care of the house and went down
into the basement and there was some
sort of faucet nozzle it's something you
had to turn on or off and and the lady
left a post-it note on it saying you
might have to turn it a little hard and
my husband said it's a little fussy and
my buddy just went up and just
immediately turned it with no problem at
all because he just mutters this guy
said we're in his house and he probably
he just said that to his wife just being
you know gentlemanly well you know into
a woman and then this my friend just
totally judged this guy that he was he
was not a man like his man that's what I
love about my friends back there how
easily you could lose your man card and
you have no idea and they won't even
tell you why they just stopped talking
to you oh it's the worst when my friends
they visited the set of Barry and you
know I'm doing all these things or
whatever and I have been assistant
uh-huh okay it's over walked over here's
your coffee
what man you can get your own coffees
now what machines the machines right
there dude just go over and get your own
goddamn coffee bill and I'm like well
I'm focused and I don't give a
you go prick why you making her get
you're gonna Mike no not you're right
you're right I should be at the machines
right there I don't know you know you're
right you know what I mean I just feel
like an [ __ ] and then I'm like why
did I invite you here to you know make
me feel bad and then hey man did you try
the desert and I'm trying not to eat
anything bad cuz you know the guys in
the military or they go [ __ ] you man no
you're dining now and I'm like yeah they
just keep you real I am I just go back
harder at them I can't well you know
yeah I'm really trying to work on my man
tits like that and that's the only way
to keep him off you do that another
friend the exact same party he was
telling me he was telling this story
he's going way you stay and I told my
hotel I was staying and he was a
construction guy goes I worked on that
he goes crazy story we were we were
putting a flagpole or something up and
he goes the [ __ ] cable Bros guy was
underneath directing the cable broken
just came slamming down on this guy
I go Jesus Christ I go did he die and he
goes did he die he was in [ __ ] pieces
and I come
well what happened he goes Oh guys were
puking some people jumped in their truck
and drove away and they got his dad was
there he had a heart attack so we're all
just sitting there like dead silence and
then he just out of nowhere he goes I it
was kind of a douche and then he goes
because his dad was a good [ __ ] and that
actually broke the tension and everybody
started laughing and I just remember
thinking like you couldn't teach
somebody know in an acting class how to
take this somebody to such a dark place
and he sensed it he sensed that a laugh
needed to come and he knew exactly where
to go yeah intuition is my friend I used
to be a PA I was a production assistant
for a long time and and I worked on this
movie James Dean in an invented life
there James Franco played James Dean and
this guy Jason Altieri who's now a big
first ad now but he was a PA and Ken
what we're talking about he had a
he had a real like Rambo knife like he
got it from the props truck and he's
just taking chunks out of his tree with
it he's just hitting this tree with his
giant knife we're all kind of sitting
there why and he's just bullshitting
wethersby's like look at this you know
this other guy bill hardy this big guy
walking over and use another PA smoking
sir hey guys and Jason he's weird this
case he pretends like he's gonna stab
him he just goes that's not funny don't
do that you know don't do that that's
not cool don't do that so bill walks
away the props guy comes over and goes I
have that same knife but it's the exact
same knife but its retractable it's
plastic it's fake you know and he does
the best piece of acting I've ever seen
just totally calm pretending to like you
know cut at the tree do everything just
waiting for bill to come back bill walks
back hey how's it going yeah you're
doing and he does this does the thing in
and then just rears back and stabs him
in the chest
why why like you just murdered my friend
just murdered and we fell down laughing
we felt bad and I've told that story to
other people that's horrible that's not
nice at all and I go I know but if you
were there it was the funniest thing I
think I'd ever seen and had she
literally got to see what would your
friend do what would he do if he died he
would say why if he got murdered
but then Jason to your point the reason
I thought of it was that he was such a
good actor he was just like you couldn't
have taught like anybody else to think
you had to get it they would want to run
over to him and go hey look in the night
and then you know what I mean that's
what I would I would have taken the
knife and walked up to him and done it
patient the patience to keep like no no
I have to keep this this this lie up
where he was pretending to do that and
we sat there waiting for him for like 15
minutes and then he
with me and her back like no we can't
call him over we can't do this I want to
be able to keep a straight face I'm
gonna worst okay when you watch somebody
do something like that as an actor do
you get something out of that watching a
guy like that yeah yeah you kind of go
oh wow the patience or so much of it too
is just kind of impersonating people or
you know or doing nothing that was the
thing he did that was good he didn't do
anything mm-hmm
do you know what I mean he just was
doing what he did before and he kind of
instinctively knew like well that's how
that's the best way to do this that's
the best way to set the trap is make it
look like nothing nothing happened
instead of I would have gone over there
I've been hey Bill come back or whatever
are those some of your favorite actors
are you a character actor guy as far as
like the guys that you watch because
you're acting on this series is
phenomenal I can't I kept calling my
wife in going look this is like the best
I'm telling you it's like the best work
I've seen and I love all the stuff that
you've done but like this to actually I
love it when they give a funny guy a
chance to show that hey I can do these
other things too oh thanks yeah so I was
just curious now that I see that you
have that in the toolbox like who are
some of your favorite actors um well I
mean it's not I mean I had a tape that
this is kind of everybody but I had a
VHS tape that had taxi driver and Raging
Bull on it and I would just watch those
a bunch and just watch Robert De Niro in
those movies he just it's kind of a
retirement he doesn't do much but he did
enough you know yes like he does the way
my it was behavior but to be honest like
I like a lot you know a lot of actors
but I was always more excited by the
story I really watch a movie for a story
but to me it's just more it's more about
observing behavior of people you know
you've watched like a documentary or I
had watched a guy like Jason Altieri do
them thing or whatever but it was the
actors who could modulate behavior
instead of pushing and making it like a
performance you know right there's a
movie called cast it's this British
movie from the late 60s and that this is
non actor this kid in it
whose phenomenal and it just is because
it's all just very genuine right you
know what I mean okay it's time for a
little bit of advertising oh look who's
back it's all zip red Crudup talk about
the challenges of finding great talent
and how the way you went about it just
did not work or was inefficient you know
I tried to dig down deep into myself to
try to be a good comedian and turned out
all they had was a bunch of [ __ ] and
dick jokes down there and it was really
tough and then I used SIPP recruiter and
all of a sudden you know I started
talking about [ __ ] taupe and my my
comedy went so I I don't [ __ ] hire
people but I know this happen this is is
this an app this product this service
let's go with that I know it works zip
recruiter knew there was a smile away so
they built a platform that finds the
right job candidates for you these
invitations have revolutionized how you
find your next hire in fact 80% of
employees who post a job on zip
recruiter get a quality candidate
through the site in just one day and zip
doesn't stop there they even spotlight
the strongest applications you receive
so you never miss a great match the
right candidates are out there is it is
how you find them businesses of all
sizes trust zip recruiter for their
hiring needs right now my listeners can
try their recruiter that's right they
can use it for free you can try it for
free just go to zip recruit accom / /
that zip recruiters are calm / bread
well my time hi sit the smartest way to
hire
okuu Sabo don't do me undies biondi's
I'm sitting in my [ __ ] car dudududu
biondi's me undies I'm driving out to a
bar I'm gonna get hammered at the bar
take your piss and my soft underwear my
balls are feel grade and undies will dry
it up you don't need no more adult
diapers me undies I made with the
sustainably sourced material from
beechwood trees made out of trees man
they're naturally soft fiber makes a
fabric that won't sag down or right up
trust me once you got a pair on you'll
get it and if you're already part of the
me undies family tell your friends about
it through their referral program though
it's like amway but with [ __ ] panties
they get a discount and you'll get a
store credit it's a win-win the undies
are sure you'll love their first pair is
so sure you'll love their first pair
that if you're not happy they'll do
whatever they can to get you the right
pair and if they can't keep them and
they'll refund you so it's really risk
free free to try the best underwear ever
still not sure well be undies has a deal
for my listeners first-time purchasers
get 20% off their first pair of me
undies and free shipping get your ass
over to me undies calm and treat
yourself to get 20% off your first pair
and free shipping and a hundred percent
satisfaction guarantee go to the undies
Ofcom slash bird that's me unease comm
slash bar unbelievable how hot your car
gets the second you shut it off and keep
the windows and doors shut oh honey when
you shop online do you suddenly turn
into a tab hoarder loading dozens and
dozens of new tabs on your browser in
search of a promo code just one that
works afraid to close any of them in
fear of missing out on a deal before you
crash your browser yet again try honey
honey it's the free browser add-on
that's overnight that over 9 million
people are using every day to save money
while they shop online and to clicks add
honey to any browser for free then shop
like you normally do honey
scans and tests millions of coupons in
the background and check out honey
a automatically applies the best coupon
honey never means honey it never does
Time magazine calls honey basically
every basically free money over nine
million people have used oh honey
every day and together they've saved
millions of dollars there's no reason
not to add honey to your browser today
I'm running out of ways to say it it's
free just takes two clicks to install
and we'll save you tons of money get
honey for free at join honeycomb / bird
that's two words
join honey dot-com / bird to start
saving with honey today that's join
honey dot-com / / write this people
next-door working on the house they
think I'm [ __ ] crazy alright he looks
everybody HELOCs there's nobody on the
planet like you so why would you buy a
[ __ ] mattress built for everyone else
next please mention all the talking
points below what I'm gonna you wrote it
I'm gonna read it working with the
world's leading sleep experts HELOCs
sleep developed a mattress at customized
that's customized to your specific
height weight and sleep preferences so
you can get the best goddamn sleepy life
at an unbelievable price here's how it
works
go to HELOCs leap comm fill out there
two minutes sleep quiz and they'll
design your custom mattress they can
even customize each side for you and
your partner in 2018 helix sleep has
taken customized sleep to the next level
with the hellix pillow the all new
pillows are fully adjustable so you can
achieve perfect comfort regardless of
sleep position or body type do you want
to kill your wife they got a pillow for
that - hellix leap has that's just a
joke helix sleep does not condone any
[ __ ] violence towards each but helix
sleep has thousands of five-star reviews
plus you get a hundred nights to try
them out tell them which hand you jerk
off with they'll have a little elbow
indentation on that side of the mattress
go to helix leave calm slash burn right
now and you get up to $125 towards your
new [ __ ] mattress that's helix sleep
calm slash bur for up to 20 $25 off your
matters Halleck sleep calm / / h e li
X sleep
[Music]
actors when they'll well I'm playing a
new guy so the guy can't walk like me
and they'll come up with like a walk
ya know those DeRosa to bring him up
again he told me was talking about John
Travolta one time he saw him and John
Travolta was like bull Vinnie Barbarino
walked like this Vincent Vega walk like
this and but it's like dude he does the
walks and I was thinking of the little
acting that I've done it's like every
character I've done walks like me they
always have to rewrite it he's a serial
killer from Boston yeah he's a Hawaiian
guy from Boston yeah I could happily
from boss yeah they couldn't justify why
wasn't from the Midwest so they said he
went to college in Boston and he picked
up the accent but for some reason he
came back here he didn't go back to the
accent he was raised by some [ __ ]
from Boston just a lot of reality TV
there's always the loud Boston guy so he
likes watching interviews with Mark
Wahlberg and yeah but he he doesn't he
doesn't have an accent and Mark Wang now
yeah I'm always amazed at how forget
that he's you can you can knock that out
somehow yeah I've watched some like I
started out with Patrice O'Neal and Dane
Cook and I saw like an old Dane Cook
stand-up thing in the last couple years
I saw it and in like the mid-90s he had
a really big time Boston actually now he
doesn't oh like I don't know how you
reading well most people like you just
sort of like if he gets somewhere new
you just sort of it just floats away or
it's just stuck in you I think I'm sort
of I mean I don't have a copy we're on
it oh yeah people work that's whatever
that people do work on it to get rid of
it and it's weird we have Bill Hader
here from air rank I am going to
pronunciate hi I'm from Boston
Massachusetts no I think yeah but I I
don't know yeah it's like I saw this
cooking show recently in this guy he was
doing something you know this [ __ ]
guy's travel and he goes Boston you come
here for a beer and a beating and I just
I was looking at if I go or you go to
look at the foliage it's just like how
many times did you watch Good Will
Hunting before you went there to steam
your asparagus that you felt you had to
go that hard
it's like there's also MIT there's
Harvard hey tasty pudding on Hasty
Pudding there's a lot of like you know
you could go get some oysters oysters
we're intubating I lived for twenty
seven years I never took a beating I
walked away from fights and I was fine
with it yeah you're tougher than me
your dad was angrier than my dad you win
I'm out of here a little poached egg on
top I [ __ ] hate the Food Network now
they used to just have people there
cooking and then teach you how to cook
and then it became you had to have a
personality and yeah
I respect his cooking but I blame that
[ __ ] Emeril Lagasse studio audience
in a band I used to be the assistant
editor and a lot of those shows on like
Iron Chef America was I don't get that
[ __ ] show okay it's supposed to be a
relaxing loving thing that you do and
they take it side and death you got to
make waffles we got stones and a and
carpet how the [ __ ] am I gonna do this
another [ __ ] of it Mario let's see what
you got we used anything of a bobby flay
like electrocuting himself he
accidentally electrocuted himself it was
really we did yeah they cut it from the
thing that he grabbed a ladle and
something happened and he just went and
just dropped out of frame oh [ __ ] yeah
yeah his heart stopped no but he dropped
and then kind of came up in the dais and
we were he always seemed like he had
indigestion to me
okay today we're gonna make it's just
like dude go off-camera and burp cuz I
liked him I like all of those guys they
all taught me what little I know but
like I used to watch multo Mario all the
time which to me was the perfect one
it's like he went over his house and he
cooked for you yeah is like being his
friend yeah and then all of a sudden it
just became like that [ __ ] guy
yelling on Iron Chef yeah or the diners
drive-ins and dives guy yeah which is
hilarious like he just looks so burnt
out on that show yeah what's his name
guy guy
he just says what you're doing like you
can make like a peanut butter and jelly
sandwich okay so you put your peanut
butter on the bread and okay and you get
some jam in there that's gonna take a
little edge off the peanut butter and he
makes so much money so much money needs
to get the hard top because he's gonna
die his skin kids that looks like a
[ __ ] lobster this is coming from a
redhead I'm telling you he's got to get
some sunblock so what can we talk about
about this everybody because this is a
podcast it's not like people are dipping
in here yeah
people know that the show is on so they
h bo is there HBO's streaming dotnet org
I mean you go to like well no I mean
Amazon or Hulu or a spiel go is the
thing HBO Go that's go yeah it's great
what would be best for you where should
they watch it I wherever they want okay
I wasn't sure
Louie had his show on FX it would be
like you know plea can you please watch
it so I get credit for people like
watching the advertisement then they
would recorded and then fast-forward it
I don't know yeah they I mean to me it's
just yeah just watch they'll be watch
the show HBO has been amazing to work
with the fact that we could go in and
pitch this show to them and we're
pitching a half-hour comedy in the two
movies I mentioned or taxi driver and
Unforgiven how did they react it like
you coming in at the okay it's Bill
Hader this is gonna be funny actly yeah
I come in with this and they go and to
their credit they were really excited
about it it actually made them more
excited how many places you did you
pitch this show well there's just HBO
because I had to deal with them and so I
had this kind of development deal with
them and and I was shooting trainwreck
actually and the whole time I was on
trainwreck going what a you know what am
I gonna do I have this deal now with HBO
but I got to write a show and so I met
with Alec Berg and then we came up with
this and then I remember pitching it to
them and thinking well if they don't
like it and only but this is what I
would rather want to do it if I could do
anything write this and the the fact
that it they were the ones going oh you
know I said you know the violence has to
be very real it's not funny Hashem
violence is not funny at all when he
fights people I like it to feel real I
just don't I don't want to be cool you
know and they are absurd
yeah like weekend at Bernie's jokes you
know what I mean
Reich which you could easily do in this
you know there's a lot of times where
you you know there's a scene in episode
3 where I you know if to strangle a guy
and there's there's in his backyard
there's all these childs you know kid
toys and stuff and I remember Alec
Bergen I was shooting a scene and and I
said you know any other place they would
be like hey can we make it funny can you
kill them with the kids jump rope or you
know can't we get some jokes in there
you know what I mean and it's like no
it's not too depressing yeah it's like
it should be no no no be he should kill
him you should still kill him but just
funny you know and you're like no but we
can I do that I said this before in the
podcast you know that's why I could
never really watch i watch Dexter
because I like the performances but I
couldn't fully commit to it because I
could just hear the industry note
where's like they went he's a serial
killer it's just like well how can we
root for that alright he just kills the
bad people he's yeah you're a killer
with a good heart and then I just was I
just never was able well that's the hard
thing that's been the nice thing that
with Barry at least is HBO you know when
we would turn in the drafts you know we
get to later in the season especially it
starts to get very definitely is not
just killing the good people you know
bang a bet you know the bad people he's
you know it gets terrible and where he
he he ends up going is is pretty rough
but it was it that was always just being
honest to that guy you know and I mean
and that that's the thing that HBO has
been great about is it will say hey is
this too much and they go well what else
is you gonna do you know they see it
from the characters standpoint they're
like whoa what's his choice I saw the
two episodes and I I actually felt for
the guy as far as like how he became
that's another thing like he's just not
like oh okay he just is born a psycho
it's like no this guy went to
Afghanistan I can see Afghanistan did
what he did over there
then got into this line of work where
he's a hitman yeah and he basically
wants to get out of it and and and just
henry winkler's characters with like the
acting class i mean i took a bunch of
acting classes i had a lot of i had up i
had some great acting teachers and I had
but but there was both sums you know
when they became like the Guru and I
can't remember this woman's name and I
only audited her class I audited to
climb in one up one class I honored it
it turned out it was Scientology oh
really
oh it's hilarious I went in there was
actor who was in Scientology goes all
you need an acting class and she sent me
there and it was acting class but was
also like Scientology so which I felt
like she should have said right that
should have been its acting but there's
a little thing so I go there I go there
on I remember we were sitting there and
and the guy teaching the class goes does
anybody have any news they want to uh
you know share with the class and
someone raise their hand and be like oh
I you know I I just booked a
three-episode arc on you know who gives
a [ __ ] on ABC and then the whole crowd
the whole audience like ridiculous ELab
ago Wow like this positive like but it
was crazy cultish and I was sitting
there like what the [ __ ] right so like
five people did that and then they go
hey we have we have we have two people
auditing the class this guy he's just
fresh here from New York he's he's an
actor he's trying to get some parts blah
blah blah blah please welcome Bill burr
and they fake clapped like I want a
Lifetime Achievement Award I remember my
face turned red I was embarrassed so you
know and then I saw the scenes in the
actors were good and everything and then
during the break like I remember the
teacher was looking here it goes what
saw was that was that too much did I
push was that was I pushing I'm sorry
yeah so then I went in and I sat down
with them and they would just and they
just kept saying everything was their
own we have our own parking we have our
own security we have our own this and I
swear to God I said Jesus Christ I feel
like I'm joining a cult like I was
trying to make a joke and he kind of
looked at me and his eyes were like
going for my right item I left that red
I said what the [ __ ] is going on so I
got out of there and then I went out of
this car I swear this is true I went
down to the comedy club and I mentioned
I said I took this acting class the
actors were really good but it was it
was it's just his [ __ ] weird vibe and
then I told him like the name of the
acting class this guy goes dude that's
[ __ ] Scientology and I don't know I
kind of felt like you know the next time
I saw that person I had that vibe like
like they put something in my drink
right like you should have said I don't
listen cuz he's a thing like I don't
judge I like I hate when people act like
oh my god those people are out of their
[ __ ] minds it's a my religion is out
of their [ __ ] minds it's just they
got enough people where they can act
cool now and they don't care if you
leave like Scientology needs people yeah
so they got it you know they gotta lock
you in a room or whatever you need to
say this is where you're going you need
to say like by the way you're going to a
church I like how they had their own
Network now to come back because that
one woman did like yeah she did all this
episodes about how like crazy that was
but I always feel like there's another
actor that could do the one about the
Catholic Church yeah banging kids and
they made it seem like it was okay and
that was the thing and you bought into
it we're getting off track here
what I'm trying to do is I just don't
want to [ __ ] sit here and ask you
about SNL and all of that [ __ ] that I
know you've answered a zillion a zillion
times I'm loving this
no that's every thing I go to is like
the word Stefan from or whatever you
know so how did you come up with that
and you come up with so I will tell you
my favorite thing I ever saw you do was
laughing uncontrollably well it was a
lock to lock a room thing Forte's yeah
will holding yeah Mike Oliver Z told me
about that you literally have the towel
I have a towel wrapped around my fault
your face because you know why cuz Forte
did this dance and he did it at the
table read on Wednesday and I just
that I can't there's no way I'm gonna be
able to make it through that that's too
frightened because he's a coach trying
to get us all riled up to go back into
the second half yeah the game and it
gets riled up he does this herb Albert
just danced as herb Albert and he does
his dance and then and and then so yeah
then I got so before we went on air I go
hey will can you just do it for me a
couple of times just in my dressing room
can you just do it so I can like laugh
and get it out that's great you know
could I just get it out so he did it but
then on air he added a move of course
he's just a [ __ ] like like he couldn't
hear me in and I lost it I just
completely lost it and I started going
and then I remember Sudeikis was next to
me no no because I started going and
then Kenan Thompson started going
because we paid manic pretty man he lost
it
Peyton I thought he kept a straight face
I don't know he kind of he starts to put
a towel around his face oh yeah he gets
because I just but I completely lost her
cuz for it also was just it was such a
fourteen thing Forte just he's not like
um on you know he's one of those guys
very Heyman I just very cool chill guy
and then he would do these ideas or
something what happened to him and you
go where's that yeah he's right now he
would make me laugh that whole period
all of those like you are you and you're
one of those guys like that was like
that was like murderers row he had at
Pete pity because I'm bill I'm going out
with a movie you know it's the movie
you're doing he's gonna do a movie
that's how to to brothers whose switch
bodies and I go yeah he goes here's the
thing they're identical twins
[Laughter]
okay and he goes I go how do people know
that they switch bodies well that's the
joke as everyone acts like well you're
acting differently that's not like you
but they're just acting they're these
people that guys so tell me sustain that
for heat 493 that out and I was like he
told me that and I laugh or I just
wanted where the hell'd you come that
and you gotta know I'm gonna write this
movie about
two guys so yeah he's just a genius and
a great guy too but yeah and that I felt
very lucky when I was there with all
those people Kristin and and Andi and
fred armisen and all those guys I mean
it was crazy
yeah and you guys have all gone on to do
stuff so right now you are you when do
you start back up with the next season
or do you get the writing it right now a
writing season two right now
oh god did you get any of a how much of
a break did you get kind a bit of a
break yeah I mean we finished all this
in August so baroque Airy was done in
August okay then it starts airing and
then you know we open up a writers room
and then you know HBO told us you know
yeah you guys can we do more and is it's
gonna be another eight mm-hmm
as of right now who knows we might
change that but right now it's eight I
kind of like that people I like being
able to craft eight episodes and kind of
make it a very you know kind of a tight
season you know in back in the day when
there was a great album a lot of times
it was eight songs yeah but then when
the 10 song came out it's like alright
here's the [ __ ] valid I'm just trying
to fill it I get it I get it it's the
same thing with TV in a way where you go
oh well now we're gonna watch an episode
that's all about you know the gardener
or something and you go I don't care
about I wanna know what else I know I'm
too jaded that I don't consider that
groundbreaking I'm just like yeah you
guys wanted an episode of I think the
series regulars are bitching about their
contract yeah guys we got to keep the
train moving let's let's do something
bad that guy guy yeah guess what you're
starting the show guess what [ __ ]
yeah you're carrying the show and if it
goes down you never play a gardener in
this town again you piece of [ __ ]
well anyways thank you so much for for
coming on man good no it's great that's
all my interviews wanted oh good I want
anybody learn anything about you I just
want to give you a break from the same
[ __ ] 20 questions but I'm so happy
for you man thank you buddy that means a
lot you've already done so much
brilliant work and the fact that you
know HBO shout-out to them for being so
cool to let a comedic actor or what I
don't know how to
what-what-what-what it is sketchy I
don't know I just know comedian what do
you I don't know like sketch actor okay
the fact about SNL and they let you do
something like that yeah and to write it
and direct I never directed before and
they let me direct stuff and I mean you
know I directed the first three episodes
and to write and all that and so yeah
just to be able to have so much faith
and I mean back to Eddie Murphy 48 hours
that the acting that he does in that
he's so goddamn funny but one that has
to be real he's incredible and now what
was was the one he got nominated for the
[ __ ] name girls dream girls yeah I
for the life of me I don't understand
why he doesn't get more stuff no he I
will say it not to but that 48 hours
scene when he goes into the redneck bar
and he you know the cowboy is one of the
few scenes in movie history where you're
like that's a movie stars just been born
yes where what with one scene it's very
rare where you can go you know like John
Wayne in stagecoach they always say they
push in on in his first shot in
stagecoach and everybody went wow you
know but Eddie Murphy in that scene I
just remember I remember I didn't see
but my my dad seen that we've been
coming back and going there's this guy
in the movies a new guy on SNL it is
like one of the funniest things he's
phenomenal you got a seat you know yeah
I
that is the best gun sounds oh yeah
Walter Hills movies always have like the
cannon unbelievable yeah unbelievable
and you know something I actually got to
do an acting gig where I played [ __ ] I'm
so bad the name Jason uh he played Mike
on Breaking Bad oh yeah he's great I got
I got to talk I got to talk to him about
being on 48 hours he's goddamn it Jack
don't Joe Joe Joe Joe Joe egos kissing
the gun and then he also got thrown over
the the buffet table in in Beverly Hills
Cop and he hasn't been one of my
favorite lines in airplane oh he was a a
goes the guy just went from five hundred
thousand
20,000 feet what an ass he's the guy in
the ringer watch him like yeah yeah yeah
he just they cut away to him he's like I
just went from it's like yeah 25,000
feet to 7,000 feet he's also the guy
they go how he doing and he opens up
it's a like a turkey and there he's like
we're almost done we're almost finished
here sir and it's like so just dumb but
he's great I mean that's one of the best
bets for the best movies but yeah I know
the gun fight the gun sounds on 48 hours
all those Walter Hill movies he always
had like a really cool sound design in
his movies he's great yeah the whole
thing actually one time I well this is
like the epilogue of the podcast this
point I was on a subway and the actor
that played Luther you know the guy from
Warriors he was sitting like right
across from me he had you know he looked
great I means like maybe 20 years ago I
saw him Wow
just the way he delivered that line when
he when Nick Nolte's beaten him up with
the door and he assumed I think you're
lying and the line is yeah well who
gives a [ __ ] what you think and he
doesn't yell to the word [ __ ] yeah well
who gives a [ __ ] what you think the way
he did that yeah that was like a rat
race in my family yeah he has such weird
rhythms that guy all the Warriors to I
mean like he's such a break he has such
cool way of speaking you just like yeah
well you can learn a lot for that guy
people gonna learn a lot from you
watching this up this this Sunday's
episode or go on HBO go to check it out
Barry starring Bill Hader thank you uh
thank you so much for coming on the
podcast thank you buddy
you